today on the matt walsh show the left is
in mourning over the execution of a
convicted murderer by the federal
government last night they accused
pro-lifers of being hypocrites because
some of us support the death penalty but
today we'll talk about why their
position
that the death penalty is okay for
babies but not for criminals
is really deranged and incoherent also
five headlines including rush limbaugh
causing waves by bringing up the
possibility of secession
i think that's a session would be not a
terrible idea and i'll explain why plus
our daily cancellation and much more
today on the matt wells show
[Music]
[Applause]
you know most people the fact is most
people who have credit cards and have
credit card debt are paying
a higher interest rate than they should
be and certainly than they would prefer
you know we've all i think many of us
have been in that situation
and now is a good time to think about
that and to think about
our sponsors over at lightstream
especially with the holidays now you
know this year you can give yourself the
gift of extra money in your pocket
pay off your credit card balances and
save with a credit card consolidation
loan from lightstream
you can roll your high interest credit
card payments into just one payment at a
lower rate
uh in a fixed rate like streams credit
card consolidation loans have rates as
low as 5.95
apr with auto pay an excellent discount
an excellent credit
um you get a you can also get a loan
from five thousand dollars to a hundred
thousand dollars
and the thing is there are absolutely no
fees no application fees no
origination fees no transaction fees no
prepayment penalties but usually there's
tons of fees in this case
no fees you can even get your money as
soon as the day you apply
it is that quick that fast that easy
lifestream believes that people with
good credit
deserve a better loan experience and
that's exactly what they deliver
and now during the holidays there's
there could be a better time to think
about this
start saving some money uh any time is a
good time to save money especially now
and my listeners can save even more with
an additional interest rate discount the
only way to get this discount is to go
to lightstream.com
walsh l-i-g-h-t s-t-r-e-a-m.com
walsh subject to credit approval rates
range from 5.95
apr to 19.99 apr and include 0.5
auto pay discount lowest rate requires
excellent credit terms and conditions
apply
offers are subject to change without
notice visit lightstream.comwalsh
for more information so on thursday
night leftists across the country
were stricken by grief mourning the
death of a man named bernard
brandon bernard he was as is so often
the case with
those the left choose to mourn a
convicted criminal
uh one of five federal executions
scheduled to be carried out between this
week and inauguration
if all of these executions are performed
it will make 13 total since july and
donald trump will be
as the bbc has labeled him the quote
most prolific execution president in
more than a century
the huffington post was slightly less
reserved accusing trump of going on an
end of office killing spree now it
remains to be seen whether all of these
executions in the coming weeks
will provoke the same level of
performative outrage and sorrow
in bernard's case if you happen to check
twitter on the night of his lethal
injection
you might be forgiven for thinking that
a nobel winning human rights champion or
war hero had met his demise kim
kardashian
especially broken up about it all called
bernard amazing
hopeful positive and quote selfless as
always
as always elsewhere we were urged to
say his name and remember his name to
mark down the day of his death
and remember it as a historical outrage
and atrocity
many news outlets published articles
decrying the execution
now if you're wondering what brandon
bernard actually did to earn this
punishment you'll have to read quite far
down into these articles to find the
crime described in any great detail
if it's described at all but here's an
account
of bernard's crime from the doj website
here's what they say
says brandon bernard and his accomplices
brutally murdered two youth ministers
todd and stacy bagley
on a military reservation in 1999.
after todd bagley agreed to give a ride
to several bernard's accomplices
they pointed a gun at him forced him and
stacey into the trunk of their car
and drove the couple around for hours
while attempting to steal their money in
pawn stacey's wedding ring
while locked in the trunk the couple
spoke with their abductors about god
pleaded for their lives
the abductors eventually parked on the
fort hood military reservation where
bernard and another accomplice
doused the car with lighter fluid as the
couple still locked in the trunk
sang and prayed after stacy said jesus
loves you and
jesus take care of us one of the
accomplices shot
both todd and stacey in the head killing
todd and knocking stacy unconscious
bernard then lit the car on fire killing
stacy through smoke inhalation
now bernard's many defenders cried that
he made a mistake
did a bad thing quote made poor choices
to use kim kardashian's phrasing
but you know we shouldn't execute him
now because of it they say
yes but kidnapping two people driving
them around in the trunk of their car
while they beg for their lives then
murdering them in cold blood and burning
their
bodies is not merely a poor choice
it is vile unspeakable unthinkable
shocking evil it's the kind of choice
that
once you make it you have forfeited your
right to live in a civilized society
in our country you know we don't execute
people for stealing a loaf of bread
or voicing an offensive opinion or
criticizing the government
we don't even execute people for much
more serious crimes like sexual assault
and child abuse
in order to earn the death penalty you
have to really
earn it you must act with a level of
cruelty and depravity
and indifference that just sends shivers
down the spine of any person with a
conscience
brandon bernard acted in that way and
received the punishment he deserved
because of it
now speaking of depraved indifference
and cruelty the next person in line for
a federal execution set to be carried
out
uh today i believe in fact is alfred
burjo
now already some on the left are
rallying to his defense
burjo was convicted in 2002 of killing
his two-year-old daughter
he beat her to death by bashing her head
against the windshield
and dashboard of his truck this was his
final act
of savagery towards the child who he had
already molested and tortured
whifter burned her the others on deck
are lisa montgomery
strangled a pregnant woman to death cut
her open and kidnapped her baby
corey johnson convicted of murdering
seven people
and dustin john higgs found guilty in
the murder and kidnapping of three women
now surveying this collection
of bloodthirsty monsters i find no
reason to shed any tears except for
their victims
whose stories are not told and whose
names are not put on the poster boards
or made into hashtags but with that said
you know i don't
i don't begrudge those who take a
principled and consistent stand against
the death penalty in all cases
i used to hold that view myself it's not
unreasonable to argue
that the government simply shouldn't
execute anybody no matter how monstrous
they may be
um i've come to find that argument
flawed but it's it's a it's a it's a
perfectly valid and
cogent argument all the same the problem
is that a great many of the people
rushing to defend
men like brandon bernard and alfred
burjo
are not making valid and cogent
arguments
the anti-death penalty argument is
primarily advanced by those
who do not have the intellectual or
moral credibility to defend it
their answer to the question who do we
have the right to kill
is so impossibly deranged that you
wonder how a person can hold such a view
and still manage to sleep at night or
look themselves in the mirror
so let's never forget that when someone
on the left
speaks out against capital punishment
insisting as alexandria quesadilla
cortez and ayanna pressley did last
night
that we abolish the death penalty they
do not actually want
to abolish the death penalty in all
cases rather they
wish to abolish the death penalty for
convicted criminals
while still giving the death penalty to
children
the pro-abortion anti-death penalty
position suggests
that a man who tortures and rapes a
toddler before crushing her skull
against the windshield of his car
has the right to live but a child in the
womb
doesn't greater moral standing is given
to the mass murderers
and child killers than unborn infants
much greater because the infant has
absolutely no moral standing at all
by this way of thinking i mean remember
that the
pro-abortion people they believe that
the child in the womb has
zero moral standing none
uh i can understand the argument
that both the baby and the criminal have
the right to life i don't agree with it
but it's coherent okay i can even
understand
the nihilistic argument that neither
have the right to life
nobody has a right to life again i
certainly don't agree with that but it's
coherent
but the argument that only the criminal
has the right to life and the child has
no right to life is completely
incoherent morally and intellectually
it doesn't even rise to the level of
nihilism it's something even more
debased
and a whole lot more confused
but the irony is that the people who
advocate for executing children
but not child killers will often make
the hypocrisy charge
against those who take the opposite view
we hear this over and over again we
heard it a lot last night
they insist that somehow it's
inconsistent and convoluted to be
anti-abortion and pro-death penalty
but there is nothing illogical or
strange about this position at all
i mean even some pro-lifers we'll say
we'll we'll make this same case there's
some that
somehow there's there's an inconsistency
here
no we who hold this position believe
that it is always wrong to intentionally
kill
a defenseless and innocent person
those are the three qualifiers
intentionally kill defenseless
innocent we do not believe
that it is always wrong to kill anyone
at all under any circumstance
almost nobody believes that save quakers
and the rare libertarian who actually
takes his rhetoric to its logical
conclusion
everybody else accepts that sometimes
it's okay to kill a person
now we who hold this view suggest that
sometimes includes self-defense
war and executing convicted murderers
the left would say that sometimes means
perhaps self-defense in war and also
babies in the womb
that's their position that is the
inconsistent position
that is what makes no sense whatsoever
no moral sense anyway
so this is not ground that we can see to
them and and and pretend that there's
some sort of inconsistency
in being pro-life and pro-death penalty
i'll say it again one more time just
just to be very clear about this
our position is that it's wrong to
execute babies
but that doesn't mean it's wrong to
execute a man who for example
beats his two-year-old daughter to death
against the windshield
that's the position their position
is utterly deranged completely
incoherent
and we should remember that especially
in the days ahead when they are
lamenting uh these executions
carried out against people who
absolutely deserve it deserve it and
have earned it
and it's as simple as that now let's get
to our five headlines
[Music]
before we get to our five headlines
today anyone who struggles with
car sickness uh you you know how how
awful and and miserable it can be you
know especially if you're and this has
always been a problem for me
car seeing this my whole life as a child
i thought i would grow out of it never
did
so many things i haven't grown out of
carsing this is one of them now i've
passed it on to my daughter
uh i don't know if there's a genetic
component to it or not but she gets she
gets very carsick
car sick as well uh and it really is
it's it's a big problem especially
if you're driving in an uber or
something and you start to feel like
you're going to puke
you don't want to tell the person to
pull over because that's embarrassing
also you don't want to puke in the uber
uh so
you know that's and now now you're in
the middle of a crisis
that you're dealing with here's here's
something instead get relief banned
relief ban is the
number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that has been clinically
proven to relieve nausea and vomiting
uh associated with motion sickness
morning sickness chemotherapy anxiety
hangovers migraines and so much more
the product is 100 drug-free it's
non-drowsy so you're not taking other
pills you can take
but uh they don't work as well and also
they make you tired
and you you might be in a situation
where you can't be tired for the rest of
the day
the technology was originally developed
over 20 years ago in hospitals to
relieve nausea from patients but now
through a leaf band it's available to
the masses
the leaf band is the only
over-the-counter wearable device
that's been used in hospitals and
oncology clinics to treat nausea and
vomiting
i've worn the relief band myself over
the last few weeks
uh when i you know i'm in an occasion in
the back of a car and it works
tremendously have not had a problem with
nausea since i started using it this
holiday season
helps someone reclaim their life from
the fear of nausea right now relief ban
has an exclusive offer just for matt
walsh listeners
if you go to reliefband.com use promo
code walsh
you'll receive 20 off you don't want to
miss this deal head to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com and use our
promo code walsh for 20
off all right i wanted to uh play this
for you this has gotten a lot of
attention this week
media matters highlighted it because i
guess we're supposed to be disturbed or
offended
or something by it by this clip from
rush limbaugh um
but but you know i know that when media
matters highlights my
supposedly offensive moments the clips
that they pull are
always my best stuff they always pull
stuff where i'm like yeah that's that's
pretty good that's
you guys did a good job thank you for
the promotion um and they do the same
thing here with rush because this clip
which is supposed to be extremist and
offensive
i find to be quite insightful and
correct as is often the case with rush
limbaugh
uh take a listen i actually think
and i've referenced this i've alluded to
this a couple of times
because i've seen others allude to this
i actually
think that we're trending toward
secession
i see more and more people asking what
in the world do we have in common with
the people who
live in say new york what is there
that makes us believe that there is
enough of us there
to even have a chance at winning new
york
especially if you're talking about votes
i see a lot of bloggers i can't think of
names right now a lot of bloggers have
written extensively about
how distant and separated and how
much more separated our culture is
becoming politically
and that it can't go on this way there
cannot be
a peaceful coexistence
of two completely different theories of
life
theories of government theories of how
we manage our affairs
we can't be in this dire a conflict
without something giving somewhere along
the way
yeah um and i i think i'm one of those
bloggers that's uh that's written
extensively about this myself and
i think that's exactly right any any any
and uh i think the way he summarizes it
there is
is uh well put uh that that is the
problem
you know in order to i've made this
point so many times but this
this is this is the reality that we have
to deal with
in order to have a country
um in order to be a country in order to
be a people
we have to be united by something it's
right there in the name united states of
america
okay so we're united great but around
what
so unity just for the sake of unity
is not enough you gotta be united around
something buy something
for something if somebody walks up to
you on the street and says hey let's
unite
your question is your immediate response
is going to be
what do you mean for why what are we
doing i'm not just going to class pam's
hands with you and
and run off into the sunset i got to
know what the point is here
so in america what are we united
by um around for through
what is it is it is it merely
geography and that's it is that the only
thing that holds us together as a
country is that all it is now to be
american is just to live here and we
know even there the problem is that that
those distinctions are being erased
because we have such porous borders
but even putting that aside you know
pretending that our border was was
actually protected and
and uh and we had these clear geographic
boundaries that were
that were defended um still i would say
that's not quite enough
there's got to be something else now you
look at other countries around the world
they have a lot of commonality you know
they've got a shared
heritage um they've got shared
traditions
um a lot of times they have a shared
religion you know they've
many things in common um we don't have
that
i mean we don't even have a shared
language
now you might say that well america has
never quite been
united in that way to the same degree as
other countries especially not religion
you know we've never been a country
where everybody has the same religion
fine yeah well then what what did it
used to be used to be
we were united around ideas beliefs
we all had a say the same basic
conviction and belief
in the dignity of the human person uh
the
belief in god belief in liberty
these things now we never we never uh
brought these ideas fully to fruition
we're always inconsistent in our
application of them there's there's of
course always been conflict around them
but at least there was some at at some
basic
level really fundamental level there was
something there something in common
and we just don't have that anymore we
don't
you know you get you get a bunch of
random people in a room from all across
the country
and you find what can they agree on can
you get agreement among these people
even a majority of these people on
anything at all
anything no
they won't even be able to be able to
agree on like
what some can men get pregnant even a
question like that
be no agreement these are people living
in different realities
is the problem so it's not just that
it's like we're living in different
countries already
it is that but it's like we're living in
different universes different realities
different uh it's like we're living in
parallel universes
we just talked about it in the opening
monologue
i mean someone someone who believes for
example
that it's okay to execute a baby but not
a criminal
it's that's not just a difference of
opinion with me
okay if that's your view i don't even i
i cannot understand anything about you
you might as well be from mars
that is how completely deranged and
incoherent that view is to me
i cannot relate to you on any level if
that's your view
and so that's that's the situation we're
in now
um and it's not really sustainable
the question is what can we do about it
um well here's one here was one now this
was proposed
i think it was supposed to be sort of a
joke against conservatives but
this leftist on twitter amy siskind and
i don't know
who she is or what she does because she
has me blocked so i can't look at her
bio but she proposed this
um and then deleted the tweet she she
proposed it because she was trying to
make fun of conservatives and then all
the conservatives saw it and we all said
that looks great i love it and so she
took it down
but here's her suggestion she has a
proposed map of how we break things up
how we uh
how we achieve an amicable divorce and
here's her map
um basically her idea is that the the
blue states will be
subsumed by canada and so will form a
united states of canada
and so then you know the the northeast
california the west coast uh all the
blue states they're going to go up and
they're going to be part of the united
states of canada
and then the rest the red states are
jesus land
and she even gave us a [ __ ] we got a
flag here it's an american flag but with
a cross on it pretty great flag i like
it
and uh and that's how that's how she
suggests that we we break things up i
look at that i review this proposal and
i have to say
to mrs siskind i i've reviewed your
proposal and i accept your terms
i like it a couple of problems um
now g i'll take jesus land too i'd like
to still have america in the name but uh
i would go with jesus land i like the
flag i love the flag
um my only issue is you know she's got
pennsylvania going up to the united
states of canada
i would say i think we keep pennsylvania
and maybe it's because i just moved from
pennsylvania but pennsylvania
is mostly culturally red except for like
philadelphia so what i would say is
here's my suggestion
philadelphia can can be can be taken by
new jersey
you know new jersey can carve out
philadelphia and then the rest of
pennsylvania comes to us
and in exchange i will give
arizona to the united states of canada
the only problem with this plan really
is that this means that um
that we in jesus land would have no
ports on the pacific
you know and so then there's so my
suggestion would be okay we have this we
have this divorce
then we could very easily i think um
invade and occupy
the california territory um and then
anyone who resists we'd deport them up
to canada proper
and we could take over those ports that
would be one way we could talk about
this on our own time i don't think we
should
be discussing this publicly but that's
one way of doing
of going about it all right let's move
on number two
as if to make continue to make the point
here here's a talking head on msnbc
yesterday
um talking about how we you know we
can't we simply can't get along and
we're living in different universes
here he is accusing republicans of being
mass murderers
listen and i understand i mean the real
blame here
is mitch mcconnell is the republicans as
the president is a party that does not
want to help people
that is working on one side to actually
make sure the pandemic
kills as many people as possible that
seems to be the logical consequence of
their policy
and then to make sure that all the
people who manage to survive it
despite their policy uh suffer
economically and beyond
yeah we want to make sure the pandemic
kills as many people as possible
do you really believe that i'm
not even sure who this guy is but what
is that you really think that
you actually think that republicans
tens of millions of public we actually
just want people to die
is that really what you believe see
either you don't believe it but you're
willing to accuse your political rivals
of something like that
um of all being a bunch of psychopathic
killers which is a problem
or you really do believe that about us
but either way it goes back to the first
point it goes back to russia's point
how do we continue to live if you really
how could you how could we be how can i
be in the same country with someone who
thinks
i'm a mass murderer who wants people to
die of a disease
number three uh the time person of the
year was unveiled
and you know who cares really but the
winner for person of the year
was joe biden and camilla harris they're
siamese twins now i guess
they're both the person of the year not
people of the year person of the year
um they had to put camille harris on the
cover i think this is i believe this is
the first time they've done that
now the winner of presidential election
oftentimes gives pres person of the year
i don't they don't usually put the vp in
there too
but we gotta you know camel harris gets
on the cover what
again not that it matters um and of
course it's ridiculous to put joe biden
on there
also uh many more impressive people in
the country
this year or any other year but what has
camilla harris done
she embarrassed herself in the primaries
lost horribly i think she actually she
dropped out before the
before the voting even started i believe
right because she was doing so poorly in
the polls
um and then she got chosen for the vp
spot
because of her gender and skin tone and
i'm not saying that as any accusation
that's
joe biden announced ahead of time that
that that's what he was going to do
so what's the accomplishment here
but sure she's person of the year number
four from the daily wire it says on
tuesday evening
a doctor who reportedly takes care of
coven 19 patients posted a tweet
with a picture of herself in which she
claimed one of her patients hosted a
thanksgiving dinner for 22 people and
all 22 people
subsequently developed cover 19 symptoms
she concluded
we are so tired this is what she wrote
rebecca carb
she says last night one of my many
patients with covid told me she had a
large thanksgiving dinner with family 22
people
the day after one family member tested
positive since then according to my
patient
all 22 people have developed symptoms
some severe
we are so tired you know this is just
the latest
i think she she proceeded to take that
down i believe that post but
this is just the latest one we've been
seeing this all throughout
for the last several months with these
doctors and nurses
they're going on social media they're
going on tick-tock whenever they stop
dancing
or they're on cnn or msnbc and they're
just sharing all these personal details
about their patients
if we can actually believe it i don't
know that i really buy that there was a
thanksgiving dinner and
everyone there got sick in fact i say i
don't buy that let me just be clear i
don't buy that but
let's let's assume for a minute it's
true what what happened to hipaa i mean
is this not a thing anymore doctors and
nurses can
go in front of the world and talk about
their patients reveal personal details
yeah you could say well they're not
giving out names so what
and these are patients that they're
currently treating
how does the patient feel i mean do they
get permission from the patient first at
least
did she go to that patient and say hey
uh i want to talk about your family
getting sick
on on twitter and complain about it are
you okay with that
i doubt she did i just find it to be
gross
attention-seeking behavior uh five
finally i'm i'm um
let's there's a little something a
little positive right now cause it's
been a little bit heavy i think so far
on the show
uh i i am honored today to find out that
i
am in fact a hero uh that's the good
news for today if you're looking for
some good news
i am a hero i already knew i was a hero
for many reasons but
here's another one to add to the list i
am a hero for wearing glasses
i never knew it uh but i am
at least that that's how it seems
because a news anchor for abc
is being celebrated for her courage
in wearing glasses on air and pointing
it out
and uh the segment is pretty inspiring
so i'll play that for you now it's a
pretty inspiring
inspiring segment watch i just want to
say thanks to the many of you who've
reached out this week to say
that you've liked seeing me in glasses
and some of you have also asked why i'm
wearing them
here's the story i learned last week
that one of my daughters was not wearing
hers
because she was afraid of what people in
her class would say or think about her
so in a gesture of solidarity i've been
wearing mine all week to make this point
whatever people say or think about you
is none of your business
just be yourself authentically and
unapologetically
the rest will work itself out we'll
leave you now with these pictures of
some celebrities who wear their specs
proudly i hope you will share
your kids pictures with me on social
media
i will only be too happy to tell them
how beautiful
they look
incredible courage incredible courage
wearing the glasses you know i have uh
i've been wearing glasses for like 15
years
nobody has ever cared or said anything
about it
ever to me so the idea that she was
getting all she wore all these emails
what's with the glasses why are you
wearing glasses
did peop really people ask you that they
asked you why you were wearing glasses
no one has ever come up to me and said
hey why are you wearing glasses
uh because they help me see that's why
i'm wearing them
end of mystery so i'm not sure i quite
believe that
everyone was uh was was emailing her but
in fact i don't believe this was just
she was looking for an excuse to uh look
uh yeah it's it's if the story about the
daughter is true you know i'm so cynical
i don't believe anything anymore but
if the story about the daughter is true
and she really was wearing the glasses
to make the daughter feel better then
you know that's nice but you don't need
to announce it
on air and pat yourself on the back
that's when you lose all credit being a
good parent
you're wearing glasses i guess what
those are glasses that have no
prescription so that
she doesn't need them i guess doing that
for your kid's sake is great
but when you go on tv and say let me
tell you a story about a nice thing i
did for my own child
that's when you lose all credit it all
goes out the window
because you you insisted on patting
yourself on the back
um but maybe i should just you know
maybe i should just
accept the fact that it is an act of
courage to wear glasses
you're welcome everyone i hope that i've
been able to inspire you with my own
pair of spectacles
for our daily cancellation today listen
if you're experiencing a problem
uh like hair loss there is a solution
you know
it's it's not a problem that you have to
for for much of human history that was a
problem that
if if it happens it happens there's
nothing you could do about it but now
there is a solution
and you should pursue that solution
there's no reason to accept
what in fact is not inevitable anymore
neutrophil is formulated with
with uh potent botanicals to help you
grow hair as strong as you
are and it's uh it's physician
formulated to be 100
drug-free this is neutrophil it is
physician formulated to be 100
drug free they use natural clinically
affected botanicals for better hair
growth through the whole body
you can go to nutrafall.com and take
their hair wellness quiz for customized
product recommendations
that put the power to grow thicker
stronger hair
back into your hands and here's what
happens when you subscribe you'll
receive monthly deliveries so you never
miss a dose
shipping is free and you can pause or
cancel
question everybody has does it work the
answer is yes in clinical studies
neutral fall users saw thicker stronger
hair growth with less shedding in three
to six months
um whether you're experiencing you know
whatever your situations you're
experiencing thinning
whatever it is you deserve hair as
strong as you are again nutrifoal can
help you achieve
your best hair growth naturally so uh
you can grow thicker healthier hair and
support our show by going to
nutrafall.com
and using promo code walsh to get 20 off
this is their best
offer available anywhere plus free
shipping on every order get 20
off at nutrafall.com promo code walsh
again their best offer 20 off it's
spelled n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l neutral fall.com
for hair as strong as you are and uh
also as we get into the holidays
now is the time to give yourself the
gift of
the daily wire um give yourself the gift
of me
and everybody else in the daily wire and
this uh beautiful new leftist tears
tumbler these are
the the most coveted drinking vessels in
the world in fact uh sort of the holy
grail now
of drinking vessels and it's new and
improved you can get one of those those
if you become a daily wire member
you also get a lot more you get a lot of
great content if you become a daily wire
member the michael knowles show
is now five days a week we're adding
prageru's entire catalog we've got
candace owens joining the daily wire
we've got uh investigative journalism
we've got movies coming out we've got so
much
you can go outside the narrative and
come over to dailywire.com
so what you got to do is go to
dailywire.com subscribe
and do that now and be a part
of what we have coming up in the new
year it's really exciting now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we are
canceling the dreaded
the stupid the pointless pay it forward
drive through chains now if you aren't
familiar with this thoroughly first
world phenomenon here's a story about
the latest one to pop up from cnn
uh there's a bunch of stories about this
let yesterday but this the cnn says what
started as a random act of kindness from
one man
paying the paying for the car behind him
in a dairy queen drive-thru
resulted in over 900 cars also taking
part in the pay it forward chain
at a drive-through in brainerd minnesota
over 100 miles north of minneapolis
people stepped up in a small way to show
one another that they care
tina jensen the store manager one of the
two dairy queens in town told cnn
a man came by the drive-through window
on thursday and asked if he could pay
for his meal and for the car behind him
jensen told her cashier this tends to
happen once in a while but at most it
lasts for 15 or 20 cars
cars and fizzles out this time the chain
continued for two and a half days
with over 900 cars participating raking
in 10 000
in sales when the next customer came to
the fast food chains window
jensen explained what the man in front
of them had done and the act of kindness
continued to multiply jensen said
there's all different types of
ways to help people i think this touched
a lot of people that we didn't even know
it touched deeper than we know
and you don't know what's going on in a
person's life when the chain closed
for the night on thursday one car left
ten dollars to begin the chain
back up on friday morning and then the
same thing happened on friday night and
it began on saturday morning
okay so that's how it works somebody
pays for the meal of the person behind
them in line
then that person pays for the person
behind them and on and on it goes
but do you know who the real hero in
this story is not the first person to
pay for the next person no
the real hero is whoever broke the chain
and simply accepted the charity from the
person in front
and drove away leaving the person behind
them to pay for their own damned
fudge sundae all of the people in
between the first guy
who may have been well intentioned but
should have thought more about the
consequences of his actions
and the last guy who had the courage to
end the whole charade everybody else
these were just sheep they weren't
performing acts of kindness this wasn't
charity
they did it because they were too
embarrassed and felt too much social
pressure
not to do it if it's charity at all it's
coerced charity and not for a meaningful
cause either
the people in the drive drive-thru line
have disposable income that they were
already
planning to spend on the same kind of
junk that you're buying they don't need
your money
really this kind of charity if it is
charity at all again is similar to the
sort of charity that you perform
when you're checking out at the grocery
store and the cashier asks if you want
to round up
and donate your change to you know
orphaned
sea otters or whatever the only reason
you say yes
is because you'd feel like a cheap ass
refusing to give your 27 cents to the
sea otters
it's not something that comes from the
kindness of your heart
if you wanted to help the sea otters on
your own time you would
right now all you want to do is pay for
your carton of eggs and your package of
paper towels
and leave the grocery store is taking
advantage of your sense of shame
to build another few cents out of you
another few cents of which they will
surely take a cut by the way
but while the grocery store charity
gambit is a calculated ploy to take
advantage of people who don't have the
spine to say no
the pay it forward chain is more of a
case of collective insanity
everyone is doing it but nobody knows
why
if you want to understand how crazy it
is imagine how it would come across if
you took
you know take take the fast food and the
cars
out of the equation okay now imagine
you're standing in a long line of people
uh waiting for something and the guy in
front turns to you
gives you five dollars out of his wallet
and then suggest
that you turn around and give the person
behind you some money out of your wallet
and on and on and on
now you're all just passing money
backwards for absolutely no reason
nobody wants to be doing it or knows why
they're doing it
but it continues until some free thinker
accepts the cash from the person in
front
and says hey thanks for the money puts
it in their pocket and gives nothing to
the person behind
that person again is the admirable
character in this
strange saga now if i sound like i'm
speaking from a
place of personal trauma when i talk
about this that's because i am
i used to live near a starbucks where
this would happen frequently
i was duped by it i'm ashamed to admit
one time
and one time only i pulled up to the
window to pay for my one single coffee
for 265
and the girl at the window told me that
the bill had been paid by the guy in
front
then she informed me that they were
doing this pay it forward thing where
each person pays for the one behind
and she asked me if i wanted to
participate and told me that you know
they kept the chain going for
50 cars so far or however many it was
so i said uh yeah okay
sure and then she said okay that'll be
43.50
i had just traded in my two dollar
coffee for a whole
suv load of lattes and frappuccinos and
god only knows what else
it was the worst deal in history as
trump might have said if you'd saw it
so i drove away broken confused
my coffee now tinged with a taste of
betrayal
and i resolve then to never allow myself
to be shamed into empty gestures of
pointless charity and from then on
whenever someone in front paid for my
drink i said oh great
i accepted the free coffee drove away
with no remorse
in fact proud that i had saved others
from this farce
and even and you know when the cashier
asks me now about the sea otters i say
no thank you i don't want to help him
in fact the sea otters can go to hell
and i walk away feeling fine
though wondering if i was a little
harsher towards the sea otters than
necessary
anyway this is why the pay it forward
drive-through lines are canceled
forever and always by the way i must
also acknowledge my own debt for the
cancellation today this was inspired by
amanda presta giacomo a writer for the
daily wire
who spoke out against this yesterday the
pay it forward lines on twitter
got me thinking about this so she is the
opposite of cancelled but everybody else
in that 900 person chain in minnesota
is unfortunately cancelled today
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening have a great weekend godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nikka geneva and
production assistant mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more
see you there